get five random suggestions we'll divide
you guys up and then a freestyle rap
will occur if you are over here what
would you like a wrap about chris is the
moms chrysanthemums are they your
favorite flower sir no i just thought it
was an interesting no you just thought
it was interesting would you have a
favorite flower
sunflower sunflower what a [ __ ] favorite
flower
wow
it's one of the worst flowers it's the
east that flowers should be
judged by their rarity and difficulty to
grow like peonies you only get like a
month of the year and the [ __ ]
bastards to open and you're just like a
thing that a three-year-old can grow
i'd put it in a seat fine but chris
anthony's nice um let's come to you guys
over here what would you like a rap
about
substitute teacher that fell asleep
fantastic thank you very much
chris anthony's a substitute teacher who
fell asleep middle of the room so far
these are two pretty good suggestions
don't let me down
there was there were two so you said
training as cat and you said amish
people that use manual tractor things
instead of actual tractors ah cool yeah
amish people who use random attractive
things instead of so you mean like the
ones that are like pulled by people
pulled like horses he'll wear horses
okay cool i guess they're one step above
me i'd be such a [ __ ] amish person like
i can't even drag this everyone else is
like
robots
and schrodinger's okay cool so manual
manual tractors for the army shrouding
as cat substituted you fell asleep chris
stanton
back corner over here would you like a
wrap about a white man for the first
time in the philippines okay
discovering depression
[Music]
[Music]
homeless people on the subway are you
yourself a homeless person
absolutely yeah
partly down to this country's horrendous
treatment of veterans and uh the poor
okay
[ __ ] that guy
well homeless people on the subway amish
manual tractors schrodinger's cat a
first person white person movement
[Laughter]
[Music]
this then lovely people i'm gonna ask
you guys through my little dj booth down
here this is a freestyle that is a wrap
made up on the spot based entirely on
suggestions not written not prepared not
rehearsed and do not worry your pretty
little heads it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
totally bad
[Music]
out the bloke on the subway looking at
the homeless looking at the bums saying
let me shout it out i know it will be
fun he ain't got no shoes i can see his
toes through the socks on the end of his
feet cause those hoes tell me he's been
sleeping rougher i'm the little street
you know we can't trust gotta get
somewhere safe maybe not insane so he's
there underneath the seats on the l
train i've seen it it's happened before
a guy's been sleeping and he's blocking
the door i'm like well sir see the sign
you should check it respect it don't
block the emergency exit he looks at me
like wowzer and he makes me run away by
whipping down his trousers
in his cat a substitute teacher yeah i
have a glass see him at the front of the
room in front of the white board i say
looks like he's snoozing i'm not quite
sure so i check it out i take a bit of
paper i bundle it up into a sphere and i
make sure i've got the aim that my name
steph curry and it hits him on his thing
he doesn't wake up in a hurry
[Applause]
[Music]
that you won't be alive and you will not
be dead getting the kind of big state
half between kind of carried on the
little membrane scene that he would
treat that cat put it there in the box
get a tiny little hammer and it would
knock up on the outside of some uranium
as a physicist he was like it's such fun
to kill tightness
gotta do it how many times they got nine
lives and so you have fun of course you
could use a dead cat or you could flog a
dead horse if you're amish
[Applause]
[Music]
do you understand put the forest in the
land and the horse with the hands you
can measure that i'm pulling up all of
the grain i'm putting all the seeds and
sowing this insane i wanna go somewhere
warner but not spain so it's the
philippines and who can blame me i'm
there
[Applause]
searching for a prostitute well amazing
he's out there in manila and what's his
skin color kind of like vanilla
[Applause]